on va maintenant comme chaque soir cette
semaine
ouvrir notre second débat consacré au
défi énergétique que la France doit
relever aujourd'hui je vous propose
explorer les énergies du futur hydrogène
fusion bioluminescence et même de
l'urine pour remplacer les engrais
chimiques très énergivores on va
découvrir tout ça vous serez surpris mes
d'abord notre reportage sur une solution
qui existe déjà la géothermie voici
comment se chauffe la commune de
Vélizy-Villacoublay dans les Yvelines
Audrey
les habitants de Vélizy-Villacoublay en
région parisienne pourront profiter de
leur piscine tout l'hiver en pleine
flambée des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité le mersavou c'est quelque
part une fierté de pas avoir le sujet de
l'énergie pour chauffer la piscine si
l'énergie n'est pas un sujet c'est que
le chauffage urbain devait Lisi
fonctionne en grande partie grâce à la
géothermie le chauffage de la piscine
nous coûte à l'année 110.000 euros si on
était resté en 100% de gaz il serait
passé à 750 000 euros tout commence par
un pari un peu fou en 2019
on avait déjà eu voulu faire de la
géothermie quand on avait fait une
grosse rénovation urbaine mais à
l'époque les technologies permettaient
pas et là
techniquement les études montrent
avaient du sens et on a décidé de se
lancer en fait dans cette technologie
avec bien sûr le risque de la première
mais en général on aime bien être
expérimental après c'est une première à
25 millions il fallait quand même pas
trop se tromper une première mondiale
même financée en partie par la Région et
le ministère de la transition écologique
ique il faut d'aborder à plus d'un
kilomètre sous terre pour capter l'eau
très chaud dès nappes en sous-sol nous
allons aller chercher donc à 1500 mètres
de profondeur une eau chaude à 65 degrés
c'est eau chaude va remonter par le puit
producteur ensuite passer derrière le
bâtiment qui est la balle ce qu'on
appelle le bâtiment d'exploitation
géothermale les eaux récupérer sont
ensuite nettoyés on va les faire passer
filtre cyclonique à panier qu'on voit
juste là et qui vont récupérer toutes
les fines les poussières les bouts pour
récupérer la chaleur l'eau
passe 63 plaques d'échange qui sont
localisés dans ces circons et deux
échangeurs une fois qu'on a capté sa
chaleur 65 degrés donc l'eau est
renvoyée en sous-sol l'énergie récupérée
est ensuite décuplée par ses pompes à
chaleur 65 degrés c'est à peu près
suffisant pour faire de l'eau chaude
sanitaire l'eau chaude de nos douches
mais c'est pas suffisant pour faire du
chauffage et pompe à chaleur à le
réhausse cette eau à une température qui
va de 70 à 80 degrés voilà pour la
géothermie classique là où Vélizy est
innovante c'est qu'on utilise plusieurs
drains pour capter l'eau plusieurs
points de captation 3 points de
captation qui vont augmenter on va dire
la surface de captation et qui vont
permettre de garantir le débit qui va
servir à amener la température de 65
degrés en surface le mode échangeur la
géothermie n'est pas nouvelle mais elle
a grandement évolué elle a évolué dans
sa technologie on a parlé dans la
technologie multidrain elle a évolué
aussi dans son expertise au niveau des
terrains et aujourd'hui quand on va
chercher une température et un débit et
bien on trouve cette température et ce
débit
rose commune s'intéresse à nouveau à
cette inérable il faut un sous-sol
propice et faire quelques concessions
puisque il y a
y avait changé 12000 foyers sont
alimentés par la géothermie avelysie
tout comme les bâtiments communaux pour
les maisons individuelles c'est plus
compliqué donc là en fait vous avez
l'installation qui permet de chauffer
tout l'hôtel de ville pour une maison
individuelle c'est un investissement qui
est pas à la mesure s'il reste quelques
freins la géothermie délaissée par le
passé car trop onéreuse et peut-être en
passe de prendre sa revanche Emmanuel
Macron l'a classé dans les énergies à
développer de toute urgence ou comment
une vieille énergie devient une énergie
du futur voilà pourquoi on a choisi ce
thème pour ouvrir notre débat Sandra et
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes là
fondatrice la directrice générale de
glowy Nicolas goldber bonsoir bienvenue
à vous aussi expert conseil en énergie
chez Columbus consulting et responsable
énergie aussi tant que Téra au cercle de
réflexion Tera Yves Marignac bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi consultant sur le
nucléaire à la transition énergétique
pour le groupe
negawatts et Laetitia cruppa évidemment
éditoris politique est resté
les côtés la géothermie qui fournit quoi
à peine 1% de la chaleur produite en
France Nicolas Golberg pourtant dans
certaines régions comme l'Aquitaine
Île-de-France il y a beaucoup de
ressources en voyant le reportage vous
avez avec les prix de l'énergie depuis
quelques semaines on doit avoir beaucoup
d'élus se réintéresser à cette question
surtout avec cette crise il y a beaucoup
d'élus qui se réintéressent à toutes les
solutions c'est ça on voulait mettre en
oeuvre dans le cadre de la transition
climatique et qu'on se retrouve à devoir
mettre en oeuvre en urgence en raison du
renchérissement du coup des énergies
fossiles renchérissement auquel on
s'attendait à plus ou moins long terme
puisque de toute façon si on veut
atteindre la neutralité carbone il faut
se séparer des énergies fossiles donc
pour ça quelle solution on a la sobriété
c'est à dire comment est-ce qu'on
réorganise nos modes de vie pour
préserver des services mais tout en
consommant moins l'efficacité comment
est-ce que j'améliore les procédés
techniques et après il y a les énergies
bas carbone dont la géothermie fait
partie notamment pour décarboner la
chaleur puisque aujourd'hui la
production
[Musique]
aspect comme on dit de potentiels
clients est en train d'augmenter
c'est-à-dire des gens qui viennent vers
vous en disant oh là là faut qu'on
trouve une solution
de gestion cette crise qui est court
termiste et qui a comme conséquence de
se dire
investissement et donc ça c'est un vrai
danger c'est que nous aussi on voit des
des prospects qui pour le coup était
hyper intéressé sur lequel on avançait
beaucoup et qui disent mince là du coup
j'ai tellement d'augmentation que je
peux plus investir tout de suite ça
c'est des collectivités des entreprises
c'est vrai que dans ces énergies là pour
faire la transition il faut de
l'investissement et le problème que
qu'elle pose la crise aujourd'hui même
si il charge des solutions court terme
c'est que du coup ça ferait des
investissements et sur le sujet
d'éclairage puisque moi je suis sur ce
sujet là le danger c'est qu'on se dise
la solution court terme c'est d'éteindre
parfois les lampadaires alors qu'en fait
ce qu'il faut penser sur le moyen terme
c'est se dire quelle est la meilleure
méthode plus sobre d'illuminer les
villes tout en respectant le confort la
convivialité le fait de guider et donc
ça c'est forcément des choses long terme
qu'on peut difficilement penser en
pleine crise en fait
un mégawater à 1000 euros ça c'était à
la fin août Yves Marignac c'est
évidemment un drame à court terme des
conséquences budgétaires pour les
ménages les entreprises pour l'État mais
c'est aussi un déclencheur de mutation
économique on peut aussi dire ça oui
alors le drame c'est que la réponse
nécessaire parce qu'il faut protéger les
entreprises les collectivités les
services publics et les ménages c'est
différentes formes de boucliers
tarifaires
des dépenses majeures sans aucun retour
juste pour amortir cet effet sur sur les
prix et effectivement moi j'ai entendu
ces dernières semaines des économistes
tout à fait
orthodoxes
reconnaître que on aurait pu regarder
différemment les investissements des
énergies renouvelables dans l'efficacité
énergétique ces dernières années si on
avait pris en compte ne serait-ce qu'un
une forme de coup assurantial par
rapport à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
donc voilà la vous avez raison de
distinguer la question du court terme et
du long terme j'étais dans une dans une
table ronde de la semaine dernière ou un
représentant de l'Université de
dauphines expliquait que l'université va
peut-être arrêter le programme qui a été
engagé de rénovation thermique des
bâtiments parce qu'elle n'a pas les
moyens de le payer du fait de la facture
énergétique on marche sur la tête bien
sûr donc à court terme la sobriété telle
que le gouvernement la proposé avec son
plan de sobriété vraiment le moyen de
regagner des marges de manœuvre de
réduire les factures pour tout le monde
de maintenir autant que possible
l'activité et du coup de maintenir la
capacité à investir et il y a urgence la
bonne nouvelle c'est quand même que à la
fois sur ces réductions assez immédiates
parce que on a été dans le gaspillage il
y a un potentiel important et que sur
l'investissement dans des solutions
disponibles aujourd'hui il y a aussi un
potentiel énorme alors ça c'est
intéressant ce que vous avez ok
rapidement tout à l'heure Nicolas
goldber c'est à dire que ils nous font
des sols il nous faut des solutions qui
soient opérationnelles le plus vite
possible parce que il y a une urgence
climatique qui est enfin voilà on
connaît tous bon ensuite ça dépend de ce
qu'on appelle le plus vite le plus vite
possible ce qu'on observe là de toute
façon c'est un échec du signal prix
c'est à une époque on disait on mettra
un prix sur le CO2 et naturellement tous
les investissements vont se réorienter
ce qui ne consomme pas de CO2 et on va
tout décarboner comme ça aujourd'hui on
a un signal prix en fait sur les
énergies fossiles et quel signal et quel
et quel signal prix mais on s'aperçoit
que ça ne que ça ne marche pas en fait
en réalité que quand on a un signal prix
trop élevé on a des phénomènes de
désintustrialisation d'augmentation de
la précarité énergétique et donc on a
besoin de réaliser des grands
investissements alors qu'on perd des
marges des marges de manœuvre donc il y
a un échelle de ce signal prix après les
solutions il faut les mettre en place
rapidement on a deux échéances on a la
neutralité carbone à 2050 mais 2050
c'est ça peut paraître long parce que
c'est dans 30 ans il y a 30 ans on
s'envoyait pas l'e-mail donc si on
regarde la neutralité carbone c'est un
horizon de temps aussi éloigné pour nous
qu'une époque à laquelle on s'envoyait
pas d'e-mail par contre il y a une
échéance qui est plus proche qui essaye
de 2030 où on doit diviser nos émissions
de CO2 par 2 si on veut pouvoir garder
une chance de limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1 degré et demi voire de
degré c'est pas gagné mais on voit qu'il
y a cet éc qui selon moi est au moins
aussi importante que celle de 2050 parce
que elle nous donne un horizon temps
réaliste et là effectivement il faut
mettre en oeuvre beaucoup de solutions
court terme ce que j'appelle 7 ans donc
ça laisse quand même le temps de
développer de développer certaines
infrastructures et après ce qu'on ira
chercher c'est la déco c'est la
décarbonation plus profonde et au-delà
de 2050 si on veut regarder plus loin
sur les énergies du futur mais là en
fait il faudra se demander quel intérêt
auront ces énergies là parce que
normalement en 2050 on a la neutralité
carbone en tout cas en tout cas j'espère
à plus long terme si on développe des
nouvelles technologies qu'est-ce
qu'elles apporteront comme service en
plus avec la
préservation de la biodiversité des
choses plus sobre sur sur les matériaux
l'usage des sols l'eau voilà c'est tous
ces enjeux là qu'il faudra regarder une
question qu'on pourrait se poser par
exemple sur le metaves on a fait une
mission là-dessus est-ce que on en a
vraiment besoin bref je vais pas refaire
l'émission mais moi j'ai mon avis alors
on va prendre du temps maintenant pour
découvrir donc
deux innovations et deux entreprises
la vôtre évidemment et puis une autre
juste après sans arrêt glowy la
bioluminescence comment ça marche
racontez-nous alors en fait la bb800
c'est un phénomène de production de
lumière naturelle par des organismes
vivants donc c'est la luciole sur terre
et c'est aussi plus de 80 % des
organismes marins et donc nous on
utilise des bactéries marines qui sont
naturellement bioluminescentes qu'on
cultive en laboratoire donc vous parliez
du cycle de vie global donc c'est aussi
une matière qui est bios sourcée qu'on
peut cultiver à l'infini matière qui est
biodégradable aussi en fin de vie et
donc on va créer des aquariums pour
accueillir en fait c'est ces bactéries
et qu'on va intégrer du mobilier urbain
dans le but de pas seulement remplacer
un lampadaire mais aussi de redessiner
une approche de la lumière qui est
beaucoup plus incohérence avec la
manière dont les villes fonctionnent
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire plus de
piétonnisation plus d'espaces verts etc
avec un gros avantage aussi c'est la
préservation de la biodiversité puisque
tout ça bon c'est toutes ces des
relations de cause à effet qui sont qui
sont toutes liées et donc l'avantage
d'utiliser le vivant comme on le fait
c'est vraiment de pouvoir avoir une
vision sur toute la chaîne pour des car
dans toute la chaîne alors ici sont déjà
déployés on a vu quelques photos ces
objets bioluminescents et pour quels
usage si on rentre un peu dans le détail
alors on a fait déjà aujourd'hui à peu
près une cinquantaine d'installations
éphémères
donc des collectivités notamment et là
on installe après deux ans de travail
avec la ville de Rambouillet notre
premier contrat de marché public en
décembre le premier prototype de
mobilier urbain bioluminescent dans le
but de tester vraiment son opérabilité
sa résistance aussi dans un milieu
urbain qui est quand même très hostile
et donc
interrompre il remplace un mobilier déjà
existant où il vient en plus c'est une
unité pas spécialement le but c'est de
tester vraiment la cohérence mais par
contre tous les projets sur lesquels on
travaille on travaille sur plus une
cinquantaine de projets d'aménagement
aujourd'hui ou souvent c'est sur des
zones où on repart d'une feuille blanche
pour pas justement aller rajouter des
points lumineux et donc là où on
s'intéresse vraiment à des
réaménagements de place à des
réaménagements de quartiers à des
réaménagements de gare de pôles de gare
à des aménagements d'espaces verts dans
le but de créer vraiment cette nouvelle
approche de la lumière en séparant de
l'approche traditionnelle du lampadaire
de l'État oui on a eu des aides de
l'État français et aussi un gros soutien
de la Commission européenne avec une
belle subvention qu'on a eu en 2020
ce qui ce qui nous a permis vraiment
d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans la dans
la recherche de développement et
s'attaque à ce marché du mobilier de
recherche et développement ça va faire
quasiment 8 ans maintenant alors 8 ans
d'entrepreneuriat donc avec des hauts
des bas des moments rapides des moments
rapides mais forcément la biotechnologie
ça c'est long là on arrive vraiment à un
tournant où on est très proche de
pouvoir déployer les systèmes mais
forcément ça prend du temps et c'est pas
forcément facile de trouver des
investisseurs qui sont capables
d'investir sur ces sujets-là qui
prennent du temps et qui en plus
adressent à des marchés publics puisque
c'est pas forcément les marchés les plus
faciles à aborder et les plus rentables
rapidement un exemple de ce qu'on
appelle aussi le biomimétisme moi je
trouve ça fascinant parce que faut
jamais oublier que la planète ça fait la
nature ça fait quoi 4 milliards d'années
que elle fait de la recherche et
développement donc si on peut s'en
aspirer c'est pas une mauvaise idée un
autre exemple tout de suite et je me
tourne vers un invité qui est avec nous
en duplex en visioconférence Michael
russe qui est fondateur et président de
toupie organique bonsoir bienvenue alors
votre idée géniale c'est d'utiliser
l'urine notre urine pour faire quoi
bonsoir effectivement nous l'idée c'est
d'utiliser l'urine humaine pour pas mal
de choses en fait
tout le monde sait qu'on peut utiliser
l'urine comme un anglais c'est assez
connu parce que ça ça concentre pas mal
de nutriments intéressants pour
l'agriculture et nous en fait on utilise
l'urine comme un milieu de culture de
fermentation pour faire croître des
micro-organismes d'intérêt justement
agricole donc il permet de remplacer des
engrais des pesticides mais aussi tout
un tas d'applications fermentation
industrielles comme de l'enrichissement
protéique où là glowy a cité les
bactéries marines j'imagine qu'elles ont
besoin de la substrat nutritif en fait
on peut remplacer pas mal de choses avec
l'urine voilà ce qu'on fait avec l'urine
alors si je rentre dans le détail pardon
de vous interrompre de l'utilisation
pour les agriculteurs c'est vraiment
aussi efficace que les intrants comme on
dit les intrants chimiques
bien sûr en fait ça dépend des cas vous
savez c'est du vivant donc c'est jamais
si facile mais si je prends un exemple
extrêmement concret et scientifiquement
absolument béton ça fait 40 ans que pour
la culture du soja on n'utilise plus
d'engrais minéral on utilise une
bactérie symbiotique du soja donc il vit
en symbiose avec la racine du soja et
qui permet au soja de capter l'azote
atmosphérique donc en fait on a plus
besoin d'amener de l'azote exogène
maintenant en fait on a montré que cette
bactérie là on est capable de la
produire sur base urine à la même
concentration dans le milieu avec la
même efficacité en champ sauf qu'on a
évidemment des coûts de production qui
sont plus faibles donc un coût d'accès
pour l'agriculteur qui est plus faible
et surtout on ne dépend on ne dépense
plus d'argent dans les stations
d'épuration pour détruire tous les
nutriments qui sont présents dans
l'urine aujourd'hui on a un système
absolument linéaire c'est on utilise
beaucoup de ressources fossiles pour
produire des engrais on les utilise et
ensuite on utilise autant de ressources
fossiles pour détruire les Anglais en
station d'épuration c'est un non-sens
absolu alors je vais vous poser une
double question la première partie elle
est futiles mais je suis obligé de vous
poser la question et la deuxième elle
est plus importante est-ce que ça sent
mauvais voilà je suis obligé de vous
poser la question et parce que quand
même je suis sûr que tout le monde tous
les gens qui nous écoutent sur la pause
et puis surtout vous en êtes où votre
votre développement est-ce que vous
commencez à produire voilà le parce
qu'on parlait de la durée de la
recherche et développement dans des dans
des innovations comme celle-là
alors non il y a pas d'odeur parce que
justement on est sur des applications de
fermentation donc en fait ce qui sent
mauvais dans l'urine c'est qu'en l'urée
qui est présente dans l'urine se
transforme en ammoniac au contact de
l'air nous on stabilise l'urine et
ensuite l'azote est consommée par les
bactéries donc on va plutôt avoir une
odeur qui ressemble à une odeur de bière
et sur la durée nous la société a trois
ans
donc on est allé je pense même très très
vite face à un cas d'école parce qu'on a
quatre brevets internationaux on a
plusieurs produits homologués on a une
première unité industrielle qui a été
inaugurée il y a deux mois donc dans le
Sud Gironde qui est capable de traiter
250 ml d'urine par an et cette usine en
fait tout ce qu'elle peut produire est
vendu sur les deux prochaines années sur
le territoire français donc
à la fois on est allé vite mais d'un
autre côté il y a tellement à faire
qu'il faudrait aller beaucoup plus vite
beaucoup plus vite je reviens vers vous
dans un instant merci de ce témoignage
Nicolas Goldberg on pourrait se demander
est-ce qu'une start-up qui produit de
l'engrais à base d'urine fait dans un
débat sur les énergies du futur mais il
faut rappeler que les
80% du coût de production des engrais
azotés ça vient du gaz naturel
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
l'engrais aujourd'hui ça utilise le gaz
naturel comme matière comme matière
première on a aussi un peu d'hydrogène
qui est utilisé pour produire de
l'engrais alors qu'on pourrait produire
des intrants de manière moins
synthétique sans utiliser des énergies
fossiles c'est plus compliqué c'est plus
un cycle quand on s'intéresse au vivant
effectivement c'est jamais très simple
quand vous regardez les projets de
méthanisation aujourd'hui qui permettent
de produire du gaz en France je sais pas
si vous savez mais on produit du gaz du
gaz en France via l'agriculture c'est
compliqué quand vous parlez de ça aux
agriculteurs ils vous disent en général
bon ben moi j'ai construit un
méthaniseur pour pour d'abord faire du
digestat pour pouvoir avoir un autre
type d'engrais dans dans mon champ en
anglais un engrais plus naturel pas
utilisé à base d'énergie fossiles puis
après j'ai commencé à produire de
l'énergie que j'ai injecté dans le
réseau donc on voit ce couplage qu'on
peut avoir là entre l'énergie
l'alimentation l'économie circulaire
qu'on peut qu'on peut créer avec les
déjections animales et humaines pour
réaliser de l'engrais et ça quelque part
c'est l'avenir en fait ce lien avec le
vivant parce qu'on parle beaucoup du
réchauffement climatique il y a un autre
péril qui nous attend qui est celui de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité donc
il va bien falloir créer un couplage
entre les deux et si on regarde la
stratégie nationale bas carbone
aujourd'hui les deux tiers de la
biomasse qui servira à notre système
énergétique viendra l'agriculture donc
là on voit des couplages des couplages
sectoriels qui pourraient être
intéressants il m'a rien qu'on a là deux
bons exemples d'innovation mais dans ce
défi énergétique planétaire faut pas
oublier que la technologie ne nous
épargnera pas la sobriété c'est vraiment
un message à faire passer dans une
émission sur les énergies c'est
essentiel mais d'une certaine manière
les deux exemples qui viennent d'être
donnés vont dans ce sens
traditionnellement quand on pense
d'abord quand on pense énergie on pense
grosse installations on pense production
et donc quand l'imaginaire de
l'innovation en matière d'énergie c'est
par exemple la fusion nucléaire donc des
trucs qui sont très lointains très gros
dont on est pas sûr même si
c'est et d'autres d'autres projets qui
sont voilà gros lointains très
incertains et qui ne répondent en rien à
l'urgence dans laquelle dans laquelle on
est donc aujourd'hui effectivement on
est dans un changement de vision les
scientifiques par rapport à l'urgence
climatique et aux solutions à mettre en
oeuvre insiste beaucoup sur la
granularité des solutions c'est à dire
plus on a des solutions relativement
simple et
déployable à petit échelle plus la
multiplication est possible et donc plus
une diffusion rapide et envisageable et
donc des solutions comme celles qui
viennent de d'être évoqués qui voilà
trouve des de l'innovation technique
mais en relation avec des usages et donc
se posent la question des usages que
l'on fait de ces ressources et donc
effectivement viennent naturellement se
connecter à la question de la sobriété
sont beaucoup plus vertueuses que les
réflexes classiques en termes
d'innovation parce que vous l'avez dit
les scénarios tous les scénarios le
montrent des scénarios qui ne
reposeraient que sur l'innovation
technologique sont trop lents à mettre
en oeuvre parce que le temps qu'on
trouve et qu'on déploie cette même
psychologiquement ça nous incite à pas
changer vous voyez ce que je veux dire
trop dangereux ne répondent pas à
l'ensemble des problèmes c'est-à-dire
non seulement le climat mais les
ressources minérales et la biodiversité
et donc pour réduire notre empreinte
d'une manière générale on ne fera pas
l'économie d'une sobriété qui doit être
une sobriété bien comprises une sobriété
une intelligence d'usage et pas du tout
une privation
comme certains aiment à le faire croire
ça c'est évidemment un débat important
allez-y oui
sur toute cette transformation c'est la
désirabilité c'est la quête durable
c'est une chose mais durable ça fait pas
vendre et d'ailleurs on l'a vu être
durable n'a pas suffi à faire la
transition par contre maintenant que les
prix augmentent l'aspect économique peut
prendre largement le dessus mais la
désirabilité des solutions est
extrêmement importante parce que sans
désirabilités les solutions n'est pas
adoptée et du coup ne sera jamais massif
alors
typiquement il faut faire rêver alors
moi j'ai un sujet qui du coup fait rêver
donc ça permet aussi de faciliter
l'adoption c'est un des intérêts de la
biominescence et je pense que c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on a cette réaction des
villes c'est que il y a un enjeu qui
répond aussi à créer plus de
convivialité plus de bien-être qui est
du coup très lié à la question du
développement durable aussi travailler
avec le vivant c'est un bon créneau
là-dessus parce que on a une connexion
avec le vivant ça s'appelle la biofilie
et ça fait que le vivant est désirable
on a envie d'aller vers lui la nature
appelle l'homme à changer ses
comportements et donc il y a quand même
un vrai sujet si on fait des solutions
qui sont pas désirables on a aucune
chance de le faire et la troisième juste
pour répondre à votre question moi je
suis designer de formation je suis
également présente personne à celle du
design et donc je vous ai tiens à faire
des beaux objets non alors le design
n'est pas justement de faire
des designers qui sont là pour penser
les usages là où le marketing
s'intéresse au marché les ingénieurs à
la technique les amis s'intéressent aux
gens qui utilisent les solutions et donc
intégrer le design dans la démarche
d'innovation et essentielle pour assurer
cette déshabilité donc cette adoption et
je reviens à la question de se briété je
reste avec vous parce que les usages que
l'on peut imaginer de des objets que
vous produisez je reviens à la question
que je posais tout à l'heure ils
pourront remplacer dans les villes des
éclairages qui finalement sont trop
puissants pour l'usage qu'on en a c'est
ça oui vous l'avez bien dit c'est trop
puissant pour ce qu'on en fait pour le
besoin qu'on a et puis la LED alors la
led a eu plein d'avantages sur la
consommation énergétique mais la LED est
beaucoup plus intense et beaucoup plus
lumineuse que l'ampleur incandescence
donc a aussi augmenté ces phénomènes-là
et notamment de pollution lumineuse qui
dérange la biodiversité et donc la
question à se poser c'est pas nous on
nous demande souvent de comparer en
termes de what enfin combien ça fait par
rapport à une ampoule en fait c'est pas
le sujet moi j'essaie pas d'être aussi
performante dans un intensité j'essaye
de répondre aux besoins que c'est
d'avoir de la lumière dans une ville et
à partir du moment où l'adolescence
montre que ce besoin de se sentir en de
pouvoir être guidé de d'avoir des points
de repère et de créer de la convivialité
il est rempli qu'on soit aussi puissant
qu'une lettre ça m'intéresse pas
finalement mais donc c'est aussi un
changement mentaliste c'est pas
remplaçant des ampoules qu'on va réussir
à faire cette transition et c'est là où
l'enjeu de sobriété rentre en compte et
cette crise pour le coup est une
opportunité de se rendre compte que
d'une part éteindre toutes les lumières
ça fonctionne pas parce que ça a déjà
été testé et là c'est une solution
d'urgence mais en terme de de vie
collective éteindre toutes les lumières
ça fonctionne pas ni en termes de
biodiversité d'ailleurs parce que si on
rallume tout d'un coup qui apprendrait
un Capri on rallume bah la biodiversité
clairement elle comprend encore moins
que si on allume pendant plusieurs
heures mais donc il y a tout un travail
comme ça à faire sur le changement
philosophique derrière l'utilisation de
la lumière sur mon marché mais sur
d'autres marchés il y a plein de plein
de réflexions comme ça allez on va
parler d'Agris voltaïsme tout de suite
si je propose à Audrey betta de nous
rejoindre de nouveau sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Audrey puisque le Sénat a
adopté la semaine dernière une
proposition de loi pour encadrer le
développement de la grivevoltaïs on
avait peut-être rappelé en quelques mots
ce que c'est d'abord oui c'est le fait
d'installer des panneaux solaires sur
des surfaces agricoles en échange la
société qui les exploitent paye un à
l'agriculteur en général ce sont des
parcelles qui produisent moins que les
autres ça peut aussi être au-dessus de
production qui ont besoin d'ombre Thomas
comme les herbes médicinales ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais c'est
important on va écouter un éleveur il
expliquait début septembre au micro de
Flora sauvage pourquoi il a fait ce
choix
il faut penser à la succession
aujourd'hui élevage vit au ralenti c'est
plus comme les années 1950 ou 60 ou tout
était florissant et on s'est dit
pourquoi ne pas un peu diversifier notre
production nous ça va nous faciliter
cette transmission d'exploitation qui
aujourd'hui est très lourde et très
lourde à supporter
c'est pas à nos un pour le fermage les
loyers sont de l'ordre de 150 euros par
hectares et par an ça peut aller jusqu'à
4000 euros pour le photovoltaïque alors
évidemment les projets prolifèrent le
Sénat a voulu fixer un cadre pour éviter
toute dérive et faire les choses de
manière raisonnée la semaine dernière il
a adopté une proposition de loi elle
interdit notamment aux installations de
prendre plus de place que la production
agricole évidemment l'idée c'est
d'éviter qu'on se retrouve avec des
panneaux solaires partout sur les
surfaces agricoles en France d'autant
qu'elles sont en train de diminuer les
installations doivent aussi être
démontables à tout moment cette
proposition de loi doit maintenant
arriver à l'Assemblée et il devrait y
avoir aussi des amendements à ce sujet
dans le texte qui arrive au Sénat sur le
développement des renouvelables merci
beaucoup Audrey ça rejoint un peu ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur les
méthaniseurs ces solutions là qui sera
évidemment en disant un vrai complément
de revenu pour les agriculteurs mais
faut pas que ça prenne la place de la
mission première qui est de nourrir la
planète quoi et de nourrir en
l'occurrence les Français effectivement
on va on va de plus en plus parler de
d'agriculture en même temps qu'on va
parler d'énergie pourquoi parce que si
on veut produire du gaz sur notre
territoire alors bien évidemment il faut
en diminuer l'usage avant là-dessus on
est tous d'accord mais à la fin il nous
restera bien du gaz à consommer d'où
est-ce que ça viendra on parle beaucoup
d'hydrogène mais il y a aussi le
biométhane vous savez on parle beaucoup
d'hydrogène alors que l'hydrogène
produit par électrolyse aujourd'hui ça
doit être 0,00 quelque chose le
biométhane le biométhane agricole
aujourd'hui c'est 2% de du gaz qu'on
consomme qu'on consomme en France
comment c'est fait en fait vous mettez
différents intrants ça peut être des
effluences ça peut être aussi des
cultures des cultures dédiées dans un
méthaniseur vous mettez des bactéries il
y a un petit peu d'électricité et tout
ça ça vous fait du gaz à la sortie ça
vous fait un digesta que vous pouvez
épandre sur vos cultures c'est la
fermentation qui pourrait fermentation
qui produit du gaz et indigestat donc
cette digesta c'est ce qui reste et ce
qu'on peut utiliser comme ce qu'on peut
considérer comme déchets mais c'est un
engrais naturel en réalité pour les
agriculteurs c'est souvent ça le premier
service par le méthaniseur bon par
contre si vous faites des cultures
dédiées partout c'est ce que vous disiez
c'est un peu absurde quand même si on
commence à créer des cultures pour faire
du du gaz bio parce qu'il y a une
demande de gaz bio enfin on marche un
peu sur la tête et on avait le même
sujet pour les biocarburant
souvenez-vous on avait dit voilà plutôt
que de faire du pétrole on fera on fera
des bio des biocarburants liquides à
base de à base de maïs bon bah du coup
le maïs vous vous produisez du carburant
avec qui sert pas à nourrir des cultures
ou des hommes donc c'est pour ça que il
faut faire attention à pas se dire qu'on
va tout faire à ISO usage à
iso-consommation d'énergie ils ont ils
au consommation c'est à même
consommation même consommation d'énergie
ça c'est sûr que ça va pas marcher et si
on revoit pas la relation au vivant la
relation au monde au monde agricole
forcément ça va pas fonctionner si on
fonctionne que en grande unité
centralisée ça ça va pas fonctionner
c'est pour ça qu'il faut fonctionner
beaucoup plus petite unités et aller
voir les agriculteurs pour voir chez eux
quels sont quels ont besoin et comment
est-ce qu'on peut créer ce couplage ce
secteur Yann ça va être le cas aussi
pour pour tout ce qui va être déchets
solides on va récupérer beaucoup de
beaucoup de déchets agricoles pour créer
de l'énergie parfois pour les brûler
dans des incinateurs pour faire de
l'électricité ou de ou de la chaleur
donc il va y avoir ce vrai couplage mais
attention il faut réduire le buzo le
besoin en amont et donc revoir l'usage
l'usage énergétique avec de la sobriété
qui peut être permise par des nouvelles
technologies alors on essaie d'être un
peu positif dans cette émission en
mettant en avant des des solutions des
innovations mais il y a quand même une
prise de parole aujourd'hui qui nous a
un peu plombé le moral c'est celle du
Secrétaire général de l'ONU et je pense
qu'il faut l'écouter c'est important
dans un débat comme comme celui que l'on
a ensemble ce soir il dit que les
engagements des États ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux climatiques en écoute
Antonio Guterres
les engagements mondiaux et nationaux en
matière de climat sont lamentablement
insuffisants la fenêtre permettant de
limiter la hausse de la température
mondiale à 1,5 degrés se referme
rapidement les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre doivent être réduites de 45 %
au cours de cette décennie or comme le
confirme le rapport d'aujourd'hui sur
les écarts d'émissions ses émissions
atteignent des niveaux dangereux et
Records et continuent d'augmenter ce que
nous dit le secrétaire général de l'ONU
on le sait depuis un certain temps c'est
qu'une course de la montre contre la
montre pardon cette engagée alors je
vous propose d'entendre tout de suite
une autre réaction à notre sonore sur ce
thème là c'est celui je la réaction
d'Emmanuel Macron lors de sa visite
enfin l'inauguration du parc éolien
maritime de Saint-Nazaire il dit quoi
sur les énergies renouvelables il faut
aller deux fois plus vite écouter trois
ans pour un projet photovoltaïque c'est
un bon objectif pour les petits projets
on doit même faire plus rapidement
[Musique]
il y en a quelques-unes quand même il y
en a pas quand même pas beaucoup donc
c'est vrai que c'est un objectif qui
augmente qui n'était pas assez pour vous
mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
trouver aussi des investisseurs c'est à
dire que la désirabilité peut-être qu'il
faut séduire les citoyens nous tous mais
d'abord les manquer Thomas et donc
l'État va mettre quand même un petit peu
aussi des principes incitatifs pour
aider la banque à aider plein dans dans
ce qui va être notre dernier chapitre
dans ce débat il nous reste 10 minutes
là les moyens pour aller plus vite
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça et
peut-être c'est une occasion de faire un
peu un bilan du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron à la matière d'abord
un mot sur sur ces mots du Secrétaire
général de l'ONU on voit bien le
contraste entre
l'action insuffisante pour ne pas dire
l'inaction dans certains cas des états
et toutes les innovations qui émergent à
une échelle beaucoup plus plus local
beaucoup plus micro et et derrière ça il
y a vraiment un sujet qui est la
nécessité de dépasser des visions
extrêmement centralisées encore une fois
une vision centrée sur des gros objets
sur des gros projets ça n'est pas comme
ça qu'on va réussir la transformation ça
n'est pas comme ça qu'on va reconnecter
les moyens de production et leur
évolution à un bon dimensionnement des
besoins et des usages et du coup le
président de la République dans son
logiciel il reste complètement enfermé
dans cette vision c'est à dire qu'on a
d'un côté un gouvernement qui nous parle
aujourd'hui de mettre en place une
sobriété structurelle et de l'autre un
président de la République alors pas
lors de ce discours là mais à Belfort
quand il a parlé du nouveau programme de
réacteurs nucléaire qui explique que le
pays doit produire plus parce que c'est
une condition de maintien du modèle
social donc on est en pleine
schizophrénie en même temps
l'électrification massive de nos usages
fait qu'on va peut-être être obligé de
produire plus la solution c'est
effectivement d'aller faire on va avoir
besoin de gros projets comme le comme le
l'éolien Auchan mais on va aussi avoir
besoin que les collectivités que les
particuliers que les petites entreprises
puissent s'emparer de solutions et les
déployer et encore une fois la bonne
nouvelle c'est que ces solutions
aujourd'hui existent et qu'on peut
largement accélérer la question du long
terme qui évoquait Nicolas Goldberg tout
à l'heure c'est-à-dire comment on va
chercher dans la durée les
transformations les plus profondes celle
là elle est pas simple mais la question
de d'accélérer aujourd'hui l'action en
s'appuyant sur tout le tissu voilà de de
de de d'organisation d'entreprises
collectivités qui veulent agir et qui
sont
empêchés de le faire par voilà des
textes alors trop trop effectivement il
y a la question des recours des textes
origines etc je voudrais redonner la
parole à Michael russe parce que vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure nous
finalement c'est aller c'est aller vite
et presque étonnamment ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que il vous a pas eu de
frein administratifs même si l'idée peut
sembler voilà surprenante il y a des
gens qui sont qui ont dû dire mais c'est
quoi cette idée donc comment ça s'est
passé
alors je vais peut-être pas répondre
directement la question en fait c'est
aller vite parce que je pense je me
jette des fleurs mais je pense qu'on
était pas mauvais mais évidemment on a
eu des freins administratifs typiquement
sur les autorisations de mise sur le
marché pour nos produits on a eu les
premières dans des pays étrangers il y a
quasiment deux ans on vient d'obtenir la
première en France il y a deux semaines
voilà mais je suis désolé je vais
prendre une minute allez-y pour que vous
compreniez de quoi on parle il y a un
super article de la revue Nature et
comme une référence scientifique basée
sur pas mal de de d'études du MIT qui a
étudié et qui s'appelle comment l'urine
va nous aider à sauver le monde ils ont
étudié le les impacts notamment
environnementaux si on généralise le
fait d'arrêter de faire pipi dans l'eau
potable et d'utiliser l'urine en
agriculture à l'échelle d'une communauté
nous prenons le Bassin parisien en
prenant la France c'est 50% des missions
de CO2 en moins
c'est 40% de consommation énergétique en
moins c'est 50% d'utilisation d'eau en
moins et 65% de pollution de tout le
cycle de l'eau en avalé des stations
d'épuration en moins on parle de ça et
la contrainte pour mettre ça en place
c'est avoir des urinoirs sans eau donc
ça ne change rien ça coûte moins cher
pour les agriculteurs
et du coup ça consomme énormément de
moins d'énergie donc en fait il y a un
moment si on veut en 2030 ou en 2035 que
ce soit généralisé mais c'est pas que
les startups qui vont le faire il faut
une volonté politique il faut dire stop
on arrête de pisser dans l'eau potable
c'est n'importe quoi typiquement c'est
pas mais à qui a envie quand on est dans
un système démocratique on a besoin
d'être élu de dire ah ben moi je vais
m'occuper du sujet urine évidemment
personne ne comprenez pas mais parce que
quand on fait pipi dans un urinoir il y
a de l'eau potable qui est utilisé pour
nettoyer le noir ben voilà donc
pour les dames qui sont présentes
évidemment nous on a on a bien enfin sur
tous les établissements qu'on est en
train d'équiper donc que ce soit collège
lycée art de repos on équipe évidemment
avec des urnes Nord masculins mais aussi
des urinoirs féminins ça existe c'est en
train de se démocratiser juste pour pour
éviter la remarque qui devrait arriver
normalement vu qu'on a des femmes sur le
plateau il y a pas de souci mais merci
d'avoir fait d'être d'avoir élargi on va
dire l'intervention parce
qu'effectivement la revue Nature c'est
une référence on les Américains
emploient l'expression game changer
voilà ça peut être une solution
effectivement qui qui a de grandes et
profonde conséquent je reste sur
mathématiques de des freins des comment
on peut aller vite parce que c'est quand
même notre objectif commun votre
témoignage à vous parce que vous avez
déposé beaucoup de brevets aussi
non mais je pense qu'il est la question
de financement reste reste importante
après quand on travaille dans les gens
comme moi c'est pas en multipliant par
10 au financement qu'on ira dix fois
plus vite mais si aussi nous on a pris 8
ans est-ce que je disais avec une
aventure entrepreneuriale c'est des
hauts des bas c'est aussi parce qu'il y
a des moments où il y avait pas de
financement et donc bah du coup il y a
plus de plus de recherches plus etc donc
forcément la question du financement
aide ça c'est c'est sûr après c'est
c'est une question de de changement des
mentalités d'accélération mais
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
avec vous quand vous dites que il faut
pas qu'on cherche des solutions miracle
qui vont régler tous les problèmes et
donc il y a déjà suffisamment de marché
de niche qui vont pouvoir faire changer
les choses pour ensuite s'élargir en
termes de oui mais il faut quand même
aussi c'est ce que disait à l'instant à
l'instant Michaël il faut quand même
aussi que l'État ou les états d'ailleurs
parce que c'est au niveau européen
certains que ça se joue mettre le paquet
sur certaines résolutions
ça nous est arrivé par le passé ça nous
bloque aujourd'hui mais des innovations
comme la mienne qui sont pas forcément
typiquement connues par tous les membres
de gouvernement il va y avoir
potentiellement des réglementations qui
vont nous bloquer sans vouloir nous
bloquer parce que elles vont mettre des
des cadres sur des choses qui juste nous
concernent pas mais finissent par du
coup nous bloquer dans le dans le
développement et donc du coup bah c'est
un peu contre-productif donc il y a
aussi un enjeu de communication que le
plus de personnes possible qui sont
capables de prendre sessions et de
changer les choses au niveau de l'État
connaissent toutes ces solutions pour ne
pas les bloquer dans leur développement
si elles sont déjà bloquées aujourd'hui
les débloquer si elles sont pas bloquées
faire en sorte de pas les bloquer la
question elle vaut pour les énergies
renouvelables également pour les projets
de de réacteurs deuxième génération
est-ce que on change le droit quoi c'est
ce que évoquer Emmanuel Macron pour
Macron pour avoir moins de recours
administratif pour accélérer les les
projets et si on change le droit avoir
un peu moins de démocratie locale d'une
certaine façon il faut aussi il faut
quand même le regarder en face et si les
riverains ont moins de pouvoir pour pour
déposer des recours pas forcément
expliquez-moi pourquoi en réalité c'est
à dire que si on change le mode d'action
avec beaucoup plus de concertation avec
beaucoup plus d'implication on pourra
aussi aller plus vite donc effectivement
il y a cette question des temps de
concertation par nos interrompre au
début pour aller plus vite après c'est
ça en tout cas moi je me souviens que
j'en avais parlé avec EDF Énergies
Renouvelables ils nous disait quand on
concert ça prend plus de temps par
contre après sur la mise en sur la mise
en œuvre on va on va plus vite donc il y
a peut-être des possibilités si on fait
bien comprendre l'intérêt des projets
d'aller plus vite donc il y a des choses
positives qu'on peut qu'on peut voir
là-dedans évidemment il y a des recours
administratifs il y a des études
environnementales et autres et si on
veut aller plus vite il faut parfois
faire sauter certains verrous mais ça ça
se concerte ça se concerte également et
c'est un choix politique qui sert un
objectif qui peut être celui de de la
décarbonation et si je voulais voir le
positif dans tout ça je dirais
qu'effectivement les déclarations du
Secrétaire général de l'ONU peuvent
paraître un peu décevantes là mais enfin
on est sur une trajectoire de
réchauffement entre 2,5 et 3,2 degrés
moi j'ai connu les trajectoires on était
sur + 4 degrés donc on est toujours pas
l'objectif 1,5 degrés on progresse on
progresse un peu et si on accélère en
prenant l'objectif de neutralité carbone
et de préservation du divan au sérieux
même peut-être qu'on y arrivera quand
les 4 degrés les 4 degrés il y a pas si
c'était il y a pas si longtemps enfin au
moment de l'accord de Paris on regardait
les trajectoires on était sur une
trajectoire plus plus 4 degrés donc
maintenant c'est la trajectoire plus 2,7
c'est si les états respectent leurs
engagements mais les respectent toujours
pas et peut-être que s'il respecte leurs
engagements on arrivera à descendre un
peu ici on a des engagements plus
ambitieux on arrivera peut-être à le
neutralité carbone avant une minute il y
a plein d'autres technologies et idées
dont on n'a pas parlé mais puisqu'on
était sur la la bioluminescence
d'origine marine les énergies marines ça
c'est une vraie piste à explorer alors
oui les énergies marines ça peut à terme
apporter des compléments mais en fait ça
n'aura pas de sens si on n'a pas avant
fait le travail de mise en oeuvre
beaucoup plus rapide qu'aujourd'hui des
énergies renouvelables disponibles
encore une fois de sobriété d'efficacité
et donc ce qui existe déjà donc vous
nous dites le soleil
l'éolien le biogaz dont on a parlé la
géothermie vers l'émission avec ça
toutes les actions qu'on peut faire pour
réduire nos consommations et tout ça
passe effectivement par plus
d'appropriation donc le paradoxe c'est
que il faut prendre le temps de cette
appropriation prendre le temps d'une
diffusion auprès des acteurs pour que
effectivement il se saisit ce même de
ces de ces solutions donc c'est tout le
paradoxe de la situation actuelle ou on
a un état de tradition très
centralisatrice qui doit réussir à
organiser cette cette diffusion
encore une fois on a tout ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui pour faire beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus vite et la l'autre
condition c'est pour ça que je
réagissais sur les licornes qui ne sont
pas vertes tout à l'heure c'est aussi
d'arrêter à un moment donné de continuer
à investir dans des solutions et dans
des options qui ne sont pas compatibles
merci avec la vision à long terme
beaucoup pardon nous interrompre mais
cette émission est terminée c'était
passionnant merci à tous d'y avoir
participé ici et en duplex à bientôt
évidemment dans ce sens public et sur
Public Sénat demain votre rendez-vous
dans la matinale l'invité Dorian Mancini
c'est le commissaire Yves Jobic ancien
patron de
l'antigan voilà je vous souhaite une
très belle soirée sur les chaînes
parlementaires et sur ce pixel art